Hắn thông tấn các xe nợa đưa tin bộ xác trưa tiên ngày 18, bắt bỏ các cáu bộ của Mỹ,
cho rằng nước này đứng sau các họ đưởng tấn công mặt, họ đã là sự biệt đặc,
nhằm phục vụ chính sách thủ để quốc quá xin tình. Nếu phân vô mộ xác trưa tin khẩn định,
Mỹ đã lan chuyên thông tin xa lại về một mối đe dọa nạn không tổng tài.
Đông thơi cảnh báo mình nhớn sẽ thực hiện các biển pháp cình thiết để bảo vệ trục quyền,
và lựa ý của ra trong khùng ra mặt. Trong khi đó các quan trưng Mỹ nhiều lần cáu bộ trưa tiên tiên hành các họ đợi mặt,
giòn nhằn đứa bảo chờ, bao gồm tấn công hệ thống, lãnh các tài sản ký tuy sấu,
và chiến khai lực gưởng công nghệ thông tin ở đúng ngoài, nhằm tạo một tài chính cho các trình chính bố ký.
Theo bộ tài chính Mỹ, các biển pháp trường phạt gần đây nhằm và cá nhân và tụi trước,
liên quan đến họ đậm công nghệ thông tin của chứ tiên, bản đa được dưới chi.
Một tương pháp Mỹ và cuộc biểu tr liên bản bây của uc cạnh báo,
các ngóm tiên tạch chú tiên, ký tuy sà dùi giò đưa vẻ hạt Ấn quan trọng tòn cầu.
Giờ phân tính nhận định các thằng ra bên trong lĩnh vực án hình mặt, có thể có thể tụi lâu thằng trong thời gian tới.